[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich bin kein meister in der küche aber
ich bin der coil master ja es ist eine
ehrliche eigene meinung bewegt dann ist
deine persönliche meinung sagst du sowas
auch so im alltag und dann meinten die
meinten diese experten zu mir ja dafür
wahrscheinlich eine million bekommen
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen video
leute und ich habe direkt eine frage an
euch und zwar bekommt ihr in letzter
zeit auf youtube auch nur noch scheiß
werbung also wirklich komplette müll
werbung mal bei mir ist es leider so
jetzt fragt sich vielleicht sebastian
was mainz mit werbung ganz einfach ich
bekomme in letzter zeit fast
ausschließlich also wirklich das heißt
fast ausschließlich es ist wirklich
ausschließlich werbung für mobile games
und 80 prozent von dieser mobile games
werbung ist fucking mafia city
ich hoffe dass ihr das nachvollziehen
können wenn ich das jetzt gerade sage
bitte sagt mir das ja auch die ganze
zeit mafia city werbung bekommt dicker
diese scheiße mit level 1 ganove level 1
gemüsehändler level 35 mafiaboss nur
noch so einen rotz den ganzen tag das
ist meine heldin zum letzten sieben tage
ihr seht es um knapp 8 schon pro tag
fast schon zu viel ist und ich bin
wirklich richtig aber das ist das thema
sondern es sind die 25 stunden die ich
in der woche auf youtube verbringen also
ich bin so newtv der selbst noch der
plattform süchtig ist und hat eiskalt 25
stunden in der woche ihr rumhängt
hier an diesem ort wo man nur noch
massive herum bekommt
[Musik]
aber jetzt bestimmt den titel und fand
schon gesehen was sich die heutige folge
nicht und matthias die 330 ein anderes
spiel als in letzter zeit auch sehr sehr
krass werbemäßig so ausgespielt wird und
gepusht wird angezeigt wird auf youtube
dieses spiel hat den namen kein master
die werden uns heute die koelnmesse
werbung anschauen und ich werde euch
sagen warum ich diese ganze kein master
sache sehr seltsam finde erst mal
vorneweg wir werden gleich sehen wie
dieses spiel köln master funktioniert
die prangt groß werden uns dass gott sie
dann freundlicherweise erklären wir
müssen von rec aber erst einmal sagen
wir bei dieser neuen master kampagne
überhaupt mitmacht und zwar sind es aber
die project fonds habe ich gerade eben
schon gesagt dann auch seinen des ju und
was mich richtig geschockt hat babys
beauty petters so dass weibliche
aushängeschild von youtube deutschland
macht auf einmal werbung für dieses
handy spielt das hat mich wirklich fast
schon geschockt und ich wirklich kurz
erkennen warum das so ist weil also ich
bin ja auch youtuber ich habe auch schon
viele viele kampagnen auf einem kanal
gemacht vor dem installieren kanal und
normalerweise ist es so bei mir in
unternehmen schreibt und sagt dass die
ein handy spiel machen
der instant abgelegt die allermeisten
youtuber machen eigentlich keine werbung
für handyspiele weil diese leute die ein
anschreiben sagen hey mach werbung von
so handy spielt haben halt meistens
einfach spiele die komplett beschissen
sind in aller regel sind die games
einfach absoluter müll und sind halt
nichts was man auf seinem kanal haben
will aber ja schon mal ein video von dem
frank rost auf ihrem kanal rhein in dem
sie auf ihrem kanal werden für köln
master machen wollen war schon eine
coole kostenlose app vorstellen und zwar
kein master macht ist ein soziales spiel
wo du dein eigenes dorf aufbauen kann
und durch von freunden können und
zerstören kann ok also ja das in einem
video 24 stunden nur kfc essen von dem
brand bros 730.000 aufrufe nach fünf
tagen hat das ist auch wieder so
das ist also die erste sache wo ich mir
in stent gedacht habe
ganz ehrlich ich will mal ganz offen mit
euch sein darüber dieses spiel ins bett
und sympathisch weil das seht ihr rechts
es hat so das prinzip von so einem
einarmigen banditen kennt ihr vielleicht
noch also diese glücksspielautomaten wo
sich das ja aus dass die halt so drei
walzen haben die sich drehenden hat
rechts und arm mit dem man das macht das
nennt man einen amiga bandit und so sich
dieses ding hier auf aus alles hat in so
eine glücksspiel optik ich sehe dann mal
und versucht meinen ohren zu greifen
alter schwede
okay okay ich bin jetzt so lange wird
die strafe bekommen da kann ich mal
angreifen
ok und man sieht jetzt auch er hat
gesagt okay er muss jetzt sagen dass
binnen bis er drei hammer hat also
dieses ding hier was man diese drehen
kann es so das zentrale element von keul
master man dreht immer dieses ding und
dann kann man etwas machen entweder
angreifen wir waren drei hammer hat oder
man kriegt ihr geschieht wenn man drei
schilder hat also alles in diesem spiel
geht von diesem komischen teil aus ja
und was es noch zusätzlich und
sympathisch macht ist dass nur fünf mal
pro stunde drehen darf wenn man nichts
für dieses spiel bezahlt also sondern
fünf mal gedreht hat und dann vielleicht
irgendwas machen darf mit ein bisschen
glück da muss man bis zu den nächsten
fünf jahren wieder eine stunde warten
geiles game einmal angreifen
reifen mit erstmal schön gerecht ja das
ist also dieses prinzip so man dreht an
diesem komischen automaten und dann darf
man mit bisschen glück irgendwas machen
in diesem spiel ja und jetzt hat er drei
hammer und kann das dorf von martin
angreifen
gratulation der wahl bestimmt ne geile
erfahrung ganz ganz kurze umfrage leute
glaubt ihr ränkespielen dieses spiel
auch wirklich oder haben die es
möglicherweise nur für dieses werbevideo
gespielt und danach nie wieder angefasst
ein dorf angegriffen
das kriegt er zurück machen und ich habe
ein halbes dorf
ich werde jetzt auch noch plündern
aufgeben so okay jetzt hat drei schweine
gezogen und dann kann er jetzt kindern
weil er scheinbar nur plündern kann wenn
der automat ihm drei schweine ausspuckte
sowie tag mich überzeugt dieses game von
dem was ich hier sehe überhaupt nicht
also für mich genau wie vor allem ein
youtube umfeld ist es wichtig dass das
produkt für das man wirkt auch wirklich
was taugt so und deswegen sagen alle aus
meinem umfeld inklusive meiner selbst
auch wir machen einfach keine werbung
für handyspiele zumindest für die
allermeisten handy spüren nicht weil die
allermeisten handyspiele kann einfach ja
einfach scheiße sind und man darüber nur
geld rein ballern soll um irgendwie
langfristig spaß dabei zu haben deswegen
finde ich das auch so krass dass das
baby dabei ist weil gut frank rost okay
da gibt es nichts mehr zu verlieren das
heißt du auch nicht wirklich viel aber
baby ist wirklich das ist ja eine
renommierte youtube in deutschland egal
was man von ihr hält dies vermisse das
aushängeschild wie youtube deutschland
und die macht dann auch werden für so
ein handy spiel das ich weiß ich finde
es irgendwie ich finde es komisch aber
genug von dem frank rost schauen wir
jetzt mal in bibis video rein das g8
falsch also ja dass irgend einen block
von baby in dem sie genommen haben was
macht das heißt julian überrascht mich
mit dem größten rosenstrauß der welt und
jetzt achtet mal spitze ohren und achtet
auf den witz denen julian jetzt gleich
macht weil der ist wirklich der ist so
schlecht das ist ein fucking verbrechen
oder ein apfel das ist dein ernst oder
ein apfel
also das ist wirklich traurig soll da
kommen mir innerlich schon die tränen
wenn ich das höre ja spaß habe ich
definitiv wir bestimmt dass du sparst du
spaß genug einen freien stunden kein
master spiel ist was du ich auf jeden
fall macht auch wie die post spielt ja
wirklich kein master also macht es ja
nicht nur für die werbevideos und für
das geld was können was euch gibt oder
oder darum dass ihr euer dorf aufbauen
und ich habe die möglichkeit dann okay
ja eigentlich selbe sache wie bei dem
frank rost wir sehen auch oben bei den
münzen im diese eine astronomisch hohe
zahl 62,5 millionen warum so die presse
als auch bibi jetzt so viele coins auf
ihrem account am ist ganz einfach und
offiziere das so dass die anbieter von
diesen spielen dann solchen youtube
dafür werbung machen einfach accounts
geben die schon geisteskrank hoch
gelevelt sind und irgendwie heran wo
andere leute schon tausende spielstunden
rein investiert haben so dass es dann im
video aussieht als würde der youtuber
diese app tatsächlich spielen was er
natürlich nicht macht natürlich spielen
die das nicht also würde mich wundert
kindersitz spielen werden aber für die
zuschauer soll so aussehen dass aber
alles noch nicht haben muss der richtige
müll kommt jetzt gleich erst wenn ich
euch die videos zeigen mit denen kein
master mit den youtube an wirkt also
passt irgendwie sich videos von den
geben lassen oder selbst videos gedreht
mit denen und spielt die dann so
ausgeschaltet die zum beispiel auf
instagram als werbung kennt ihr alle und
diesen wirklich schlimm kommt es zu dem
clip mit dem neuen master mit babys
gesicht wirkt
doch noch kein meister spielen ja ich
glaube wir kennen alle so mein mann
kommt nach hause nach einem langen
arbeitstag und sohn borja stress gehabt
auf der arbeit oder in der uni oder in
der schule
und dann setzt man sich auf dem sofa und
die erste lektion ist nicht so sondern
erst mal eine runde kein master spielen
sehr authentisch baby ist wirklich sehr
authentisch ok ja und jetzt während sie
zockt und angegriffen wird verbrennt die
irgendwas in der küche und gebt euch
jetzt was sie dann sagt gibt einfach
leute es ist wirklich einfach schlimm
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der schmerz
ne na.de wie baby wie kannst du erstmal
ist sowas überhaupt sagen können dass
gerade noch mal sehen ich bin kein
meister in der küche aber ich bin der
kein master ist das deine ehrliche
eigene meinung geblieben
dann ist deine persönliche meinung sagst
du sowas auch so im alltag oder hat
irgendwas damit zu tun dass du dir einen
riesigen batzen geld angeboten haben
weil dieser kein master ist ihr crm
sowie keusche dass ich solch ein bild
sagt das ist kein billig ist einfach
kein master was ist jetzt mit der keule
master werbung zu tun hat gar keine
ahnung oder warum sie das darin sagt
aber scheinbar www.congstar.de ja die
ganze werden du wirst doch nicht
antworten aber ich musste trotzdem
stellen wie viel geld haben sie dir
geboten dass du so was einfach sagst für
die und das auch einfach so stehen
lassen sagt wir klar
schick die werbung raus so finde ich
cool kein problem finde ich gut das
finde ich super also so kann ich gerne
so will ich gerne von deutschland
gesehen werden als master in der werbung
von dem spiel dass kein master heißt
wird ja auch zu diesen fremdschaden
leute also nie und nimmer ist es was das
baby jemals in ihrem leben so sagen
würde und man merkt es einfach sofort
dass das einfach so eine gekaufte
aussage ist ich weiß nicht also ich
finde es cool dass youtube ein product
placement geld verdienen aber dass ist
doch einfach weg sagt man nicht so ein
satz ich sag nicht so was in der werbung
es sei denn man kriegt genug geld dann
ist ja alles egal
ich hätte ehrlich gedacht dass gerade
die mit ihrer reichweite von 5,6
millionen abonnenten bisschen mehr
darauf achtet was in ihren videos zeigt
gut aber letzten endes kann ich auch
sagen wie das abgelaufen ist können
master bestimmt gesagt ja wir zahlen die
150000 euro
vielleicht 200.000 euro 300.000 euro
dafür dass du in deinem video dafür
werbung macht also ich glaube das sind
keine unrealistischen zahlen ganz kurz
heute wichtiger nachtrag ich nehme das
hier gerade auch nachdem ich das ganze
video schon aufgenommen habe und zwar
habe ich gerade auch mit experten aus
der branche gesprochen die sich sehr gut
auskennen mit dem bestimmt von wie viel
kostet zwei sehr großen sehr sehr großen
youtube reichweite kampagnen zu machen
und die beiden aber zu mir sebastian so
ganz ehrlich die zwei youtube videos
gemacht bewegt die hat den käufer das
recht gegeben einfach mit ihrem gesicht
werbung auch insider zu machen und dann
meinten die meinten diese experten zu
mir
wer dafür wahrscheinlich eine million
bekommen vielleicht anderthalb millionen
und das kommt von wirklichen experten
aus der bauleute kein gewählt oder
kranke welt und damit wie wir gesagt wir
überhaupt spielt es eine scheiß dabei
easy money und das hat schon ein
bisschen wächst was sagt ja leute habt
schon genug ihr habt schon die nase voll
nein ich könnte jetzt nicht aufhören
leute wir haben noch viel mehr werbe
clips werden hier noch einen clip von
ihm prangt groß den koloss da auch als
werbung schaltet ist okay alles klar sei
wir sehen wieder ein recht professionell
produziertes video scheinbar kein master
dann von kamera team bestellt und zu
denen hingeschickt also für ein break
groß und zu baby und auch zu seinen
gästen dann quasi professionelle
werbeclips mit youtube zu drehen problem
nur wie gesagt dass sie kaum master ist
ja alles wird ist ein fucking fische
gehen und hier bei dem frank rost ist
auch der erste bilanz aufgestellt
der eine heißt kelvin k lvn schreibt man
ihn glaube ich was steht in der werbung
und den untertitel kevin na also der
bruder ist calvin sie schreiben einfach
kevin dieker was ist das hat sich das
irgendwann noch mal angeschaut aber
nicht mehr lange
doch angreifen so weiter also richtig
schlecht gemachter frank buob tabasco
auf die pizza was ist mir im jahr 2014
so und dann sehen wir hier schon wieder
er sagt wirklich also deutlicher kann
man diesen namen nicht aussprechen er
sagt ich werde calvin storf angreifen zu
wenig kenntnis darauf angreifen warst du
dem motto titel genau kevin kevin können
was da habt ihr euch das video nochmal
angeschaut das ist eure das ist von
eurem offiziellen instagram account
gepostet sieht man doch hier das
verhältnis kevins meint kevin was hoffe
ich in den vertrag ein geschockt oder
köln master hat für die 60.000 euro die
sie euch gegeben und für die kampagne
haben auch das recht erworben dein
bruder umzubenennen
der ist jetzt kevin kevin der kaarster
ach ja jetzt wird es noch geiler leute 8
jetzt haben wir schon eine dritte
version von seinem namen geht euch das
hier oben auf dem handy dorf von calvin
auf einmal calvin mit ca
egal köln meister wie viel geld habt ihr
den gegeben dass ihr die einfach
mehrfach umbenennen dürftig dachte eine
namensänderung ist im vertrag drin
es kann doch egal jetzt aber wieder
cable mit kaffee ja er hat das ein
besoffener geschnitten wird dieses video
gemacht man die kamera aufnahmen sind
übel so die sky gerechnet das bildsignal
aus wer hat dieses video kontrolliert
ein besoffener ein blinder tauber mensch
hier stellen wir immer wieder cable
mitteilt ob köln master wie oft habt ihr
die umbenannte wasser also dann kommt
das leben gekauft so das recht die
umzubenennen so was für calvin deshalb
kevin und morgen hast du calvin aber mit
ca und dann wieder calvin mit ki warum
weil wir kein master sind und ihr team
viel geld bezahlt haben okay jetzt
schaut sie also wieder die haben einfach
dreimal rein geschissen mit dem namen in
29 sekunden
ganz davon abgesehen dass das spiel in
meinen augen auch immer weg ist reicht
nicht denn die werbung muss auch weg
sein
ok also es wirklich viele leute aber es
ist immer noch nicht genug leute wir
haben auch noch einen clip von seinen
desktop
so da sehen uns wieder also das ist
seine freundin glaube ich diese in
misano liegt auf dem bett natürlich auch
eine leidenschaftliche master spielerin
ist ja klar der also die die sieht mir
auch aus wie die eine die auf jeden fall
dann am tag fünf stunden in köln master
investiert und das zeug zum heute nein
die macht es doch nicht wegen des geldes
das spiel macht ihr wirklich spaß oder
ok sei man gerade dabei in der sauna
beim zocken okay nur mit einem handtuch
bekleidet natürlich auch seinen des jud
leidenschaftlicher kein master zocker
übels übelster kasseler in diesem spiel
auch sehr authentisch von ihm danke für
diese vorlage der kein ich habe auch
nichts gegen dieses unternehmen soll
ich habe auch nichts dagegen dass
youtuber werbung dafür machen aber ich
finde diese kombination hat einfach weg
und deswegen mache ich darüber ein video
und ich denke können was da für diese
vorlage von maser das wahrscheinlich
schlechteste spiel
geil
also sind wir ganz ehrlich leute diese
ganze sache stinkt doch zum himmel oder
einerseits kaufen die sich richtig große
youtuber 1 babys youtube alle wisst ihr
was das kostet bei der werbung zu buchen
alter die wird so viel geld dafür
bekommen frank rost auch ein großer
kanal zu einem der ist ja auf wir haben
hunderttausende euro in diese drei
youtuber investiert save herself safe
safe wir machen die werbeclips baby sagt
dass sich der chor master ist ja und
dann noch andere weil die clips wo die
punk brauchst einfach drei mal umbenannt
werden in einem clip was ist es für ein
unternehmen das das gemacht hat und dann
kommt dazu dass dieses spiel einfach
diese sagt mir ob ich darüber treiber
aber ich feiere das nicht leute ist ab
sechs jahren und das ding sieht einfach
aus wie so ein spielautomat von der
optik her
zumindest dieses teilen der mitte was
wir schon gezeigt habe sieht einfach aus
wie ein casino automaten genau so in der
nächsten spiel stehen könnte und das in
einem spiel ab sechs jahren finde ich
einfach nicht geil
und ganz ehrlich mal davon abgesehen was
ich sonst so von den youtube inhalte die
in diesem video auftauchen
ich finds auch einfach nicht cool dafür
werbung zu machen
ich finde die ganze sache ziemlich weg
leute lasst uns gerne in den kommentaren
diskutieren wie ihr das ganze gesehen
habt vielleicht etwas anders gesehen
vielleicht sich das genauso wie ich
schreibe gerne unten rein ich würde mich
freuen wenn mein abo dallas wenn euch
das video gefallen hat und wenn ihr
weiter schauen wollt könnt ihr getrieben
doch einfach ich glaube schlagen das
video abchecken
das war weit von mir ich könnte eure
augen leute bis zum nächsten mal